well it's a pleasure to be able to
contribute to genetic virtual week and
to be a keynote speaker for this session
i want to thank the folks at
lab roots of lynn brainerd in particular
uh for
for all the help uh for time for the
behind the scenes recording this
and uh all the the uh elements to make
this such a smooth process
i want to talk a little bit about
precision medicine i i chose to title
moving precision medicine from exotic to
normal
because i think we need to stop thinking
about precision medicine as something
exotic and think of it as something
normal uh
when we see a giraffe we're quite
excited it's out of the ordinary
when we see a horse it's interesting and
we love seeing them but
it's not quite as out of the ordinary
and
that's where precision medicine is going
we're seeing a lot both from the genomic
side of
other tools becoming normal just
becoming something that's part of the
way we manage patients
part of the way we identify risk that
sort of thing so i'll talk on that piece
uh
a little bit i want to first of all have
some disclosure some of the board of
directors of several companies
that are that are listed there
scientific advisor to
uh to one company uh speaker
uh dozen talks in the past so we'll
spend a few years
uh for genetech and aluminum and then
i'm in
uh in this right away so
the the problem as we know it with
precision medicine
it wasn't that long ago where the the
main focus was around biobanking
and we talked about precision medicine
but really we're talking about
taking tissues taking blood taking other
samples
tucking them away in the freezer then we
started linking them with a data
warehouse so the electronic medical
record or
some other set of data where we had
those samples and then we started
getting into some practical applications
some pharmacogenomic applications but
only the minimum
uh some tumor sequencing with just a few
genes because you have to
expand out to more genes with sequencing
start doing a prenatal uh non-invasive
prenatal testing
that started to be highly applied
across many areas of the world in terms
of
genetics and genomics and then things
have exploded where you see
lots of examples transplant genomics
pharmacogenomics for a number of
indications that we'll get into
the net nonsense the neonatal intensive
care units now
many of the high-level nicu's uh have a
24-hour turnaround
whole genome that is being applied to
identify the risks of these kids and
intervene
right away molecular microbiology is uh
is a major advance
and we see more of that coming along so
precision medicine has gone from
an idea something we may do something
that's more research-oriented
to something that is now being applied
in a routine basis uh
in many elements of of our of our life
and
if it's not in your area yet it will be
soon because we're seeing a rapid
distribution of being able to apply
precision medicine
in most parts of the world now
taking a a medication-oriented approach
the clinical problem is really a
wonderful problem
and that is that for most diseases there
are multiple active treatments that we
can choose from
now of course there's your favorite
disease that has no good treatments or
only one good treatment
but if you take common diseases or even
some of the rare diseases
you have multiple active druids so we we
need to be able to select
from a whole buffet of of options
not just this idea that there is one
king and all must bow to
to uh um and so the the
choice of from amongst these active
regiments needs to be objective
right now it's often based on
familiarity
what is available in your country uh
what it what is uh
affordable um those types of things when
really we could go even further
and look at things like i go is there
going to be variation or response and
that's
normal seen in in almost all drugs and
so can we explain some of that variation
and pick a drug with the higher
probability of a benefit
toxicity is starting to become more
predictable so we can have that as a
feature
and then of course we have the issue
that that none of us go into science to
really focus on
and that is that medications especially
new therapies
are very expensive it doesn't matter
whether you're a poor country or a rich
country
a major part of the expenditure
is around medications and and so the
idea that we can
identify medications that have a best
chance of controlling the
disease have a uh less of a chance of
of having uh systemic toxicity and then
can be done in an affordable manner
is really an important element there and
so can we use precision medicine to
achieve these goals
is what we're really seeing a lot of
growth in over the last few years and
then now
as we're as we're going forward now
probability probabilistic data is enough
in medicine we're used to using the the
chance that something might happen
as a way of intervening now it could be
something like
uh insulin for diabetes uh you don't
wait until someone has gone blind
from diabetes or has lost a kidney you
see uncontrolled glucose
you try exercise you try diet if that
doesn't work
you're intervening with medication of
some sort same with statins as a primary
secondary prevention for heart disease
you don't wait until someone has had a
heart attack you intervene early
try to get the cholesterol down try to
prevent that effect
decrease the probability that that event
will ever occur
for the individual same thing with the
antihypertensives
for stroke try to decrease the
probability you don't wait until they
have a stroke
you see uncontrolled blood pressure you
try to control the blood pressure
decreasing the probability of stroke and
so that concept
is is really quite different than we
think about for treatment
you know often we're thinking about a
treatment about some sort of
intervention
based on the disease but really we're
trying to decrease the chance of the
disease happening
at all in in most instances and i put a
picture there of a young
girl uh using uh the bowling lane the 10
pin bowling for those of you
in the in the uk side of things um and
this uh
this concept that we use the the bumpers
the
the the gutter guards as they're also
called
that can be put down it keeps the
child's ball from falling into the
gutter
it doesn't guarantee a strike but it
means that they're going to hit some
pins
and can we make it so that the
probability of disease
is dramatically decreased the chance of
going into the gutter
using this bowling metaphor is massively
decreased
and the chance of hitting some pins
having some success in terms of
controlling the disease
is much higher and so that's often what
we're trying to achieve
uh in this case same thing with breast
cancer screening or
colon cancer screening you have age as a
as an increasing probability of colon
cancer
you reach a certain age you start using
colonoscopy or some other tools
to to try to identify people at risk for
colon cancer
intervene early and either
have it in a benign or pre-premolated
state
or even catch it early in a malignant
state and decrease that
the chance of morbidity and mortality
dramatically and so again
the probability is increase is decreased
therefore we can use that and so
why don't we do more of that with
medicines you know the average drug
reactions are a common
uh leading cause of death in the united
states in the uk
in the rest of europe in australia uh
probably in every country but not every
country has looked
uh and so you see uh that average drug
reactions are
a big issue in countries like the united
states and
some other countries they're heavily
litigated
um many of these adverse events are not
predictable
and so you always have a situation where
someone takes a
dose of insulin and forgets to eat or
they take uh
three pain meds because their pain is so
bad it ends up being too much for them
but often it's uh an adverse event that
could be predicted
often by a molecular test and therefore
we can be doing better
uh in that case the if you add new
therapies they're very expensive
uh and so how does one justify those uh
you need to enrich the probability
of a benefit um in that case and that
equals better value
because you're if you're going to have
to spend money you want to make sure
that for the country's sake
for the region's sake for the
individual's sake that that money is
being well spent
to get a gain for for them in the future
and so
again lots to do we do have to consider
what is the source of the data
and the target populations on which
we're building this precision medicine
and so i mentioned that because
these are our noble goals are things
that we can aspire to
but we need to remember uh the reality
for this so for example
if you look at where drugs are are
developed you you think oh well the drug
developed with all of the world in mind
and so you're
you're really thinking about all the
different types of patients that could
be
benefiting from there and and go forward
from there
in reality it's quite restricted this is
uh some
figures from a paper that dr todd nefer
in two years ago
and one thing that it demonstrated you
know pop this up
um is if you if you look at the
participants
of these clinical trials these are
clinical trials that were used by the
usfda
as pivotal trials for the approval of a
drug
for central nervous system disease for
cardiac disease
and for cancer so very common causes of
morbidity and mortality
uh in every country in the world and so
if you look at the approvals
back in 1996 92 of the participants
were white and there was some small
contribution
from african-american or other black
individuals
very few asians the whole continent was
not well represented
back at that point in time you jump
forward 17 years
and you see that 86 white more of a
contribution from asia
not much of a change in terms of african
and african americans
um and a few others contributing there
and so i mentioned this
because 16 of the world's population is
white
so if you're trying to take safety data
from these
critical pivotal efficacy and safety
trials
and apply them across the world you can
automatically see some gaps
you're not going to have well good
representation for most of the world
on these trials and so we need to
remember that as we're going forward
that the clinical trials that we're
reading about in our favorite journals
lancet
doing a journal et cetera are are going
to be
very nice and well done trials but may
not quite represent the world in the way
we might need uh depending where you you
happen to be
practicing and just to see that a
different way here are the countries
involved in the
pivotal trials back in 1997. here's what
it looked like in 2004
you can see the yellow introduction a
little bit in india
a more representation in in uh south
america
uh here's 2009 and here's 2012.
and then we have more data than that
that's the figures that put into now so
again not much reputation in africa um
some increasing reputation
representation
in asia in terms of the countries that
are involved but i showed you previously
the percentages are still low so there's
a ways to go
in terms of making sure that the data we
have can be used appropriately
to decrease the probability of bad
things happening increase the
probability of good things happening
for patients throughout the world also
the way you can look at a patient to try
to be more precise
can range with a number of different
tools it could be
tools for using nucleic acids so
dna sequencing dna methylation dna copy
number
uh it could be uh protein assays or rna
expression essays imaging either either
2d imaging or or dynamic engine
imaging with a functional imaging pet
scans
could be particle kinetics could be
circulating cells
lots of different ways we can measure a
person so i'm going to focus in on dna
because it's a practical thing dna is
analyzed in all countries in the world
dna is something that's quite stable and
therefore can transport
from a clinic in the middle of of the
wilderness
all the way through to the big city uh
without losing uh
its intended desire so it's not perfect
but it is one that where we have many
examples and we'll talk about them
but remember all these different areas
and more are
equally important and someday will be
more important
than dna as we uh as we make these uh
applications
also when it comes to medications
certainly genes are important
you see that in the upper left-hand side
here but you have drug drug interactions
drug illness interactions drug allergy
interactions
drug lifestyles food many different
variables that can influence whether a
drug is going to work well
or have an adverse event independent of
the genes
and so if we really want to achieve
precision medicine
we may depend on genetics as a major
tool for doing so
but there are other aspects including
some very practical easy to obtain
aspects
such as asking a person about their
allergies that can be quite helpful
as you uh as you move forward
now in terms of pharmacogenomics the
areas where
the genomics is known to influence a
medication so the
pharmaco for medicine genomics for the
genome
there are about 170 examples where the
usfda has included genetics
somewhere in the prescribing
recommendations the the so-called
package insert
that is available with each prescription
for the medicine
but there's only a smaller group and
it's shown here
there's maybe a few examples missing uh
that
that are in the dosing and
administration section so these are the
sections where there is data on whether
you should use the medicine
whether you should use it at a certain
dose and and how you can apply it
and that includes the number of cancer
drugs showing like the top
10 or so there and then a number of
examples where it's the
the normal dna and variation in that
normal dna
they'll answer those drugs for cardiac
disease cystic fibrosis
pain control etc uh going forward and if
you take a
chronic ill chronically ill patient
you'll see things that that really
matter
you know pain control nausea and
vomiting both
because of the disease and because of
surgery uh antidepressants
you know stimulus and blood centers it's
not just the case for precision
medicines oncology
but the tumor markers but rather a lot
of elements are there including
these elements that are important for
cancer patients so even if you want to
be oncology centric
um you can look certainly look at the
tumor markers but also
how do you support the person um as
they're going forward and so there's
opportunities
uh there as we as we push on forward
so i'm going to show you one of the
examples and it's a it's an example of
some of the data that's being generated
it's an example of some of the practical
applications that are coming out
and also of the the algorithms that are
put together that might look fancy
but often are are really quite practical
um as
you if you try to apply things so this
is an example using the drug
boriconazole this is antifungal drug
uh it's used in the context of
prophylaxis for
risk of fungal infection it's used for
treatment of some fungal infections
in the case of patients that i've been
involved with
often we're using it to prevent fungal
infection
in patients that are having a leukemia a
myeloid leukemia in particular
where their risk of death from fungal
infection can be quite high
and so introducing a antifungal like
voracozol
that medicine then can be taken
preventing
a fungal infection from occurring and
has been shown to decrease mortality
in that in that group well as some of
you will know
this particular drug can be broken down
into inactive metabolites
or certainly less active metabolites so
you do not want this to be broken down
too rapidly or else you won't get the
desired effect and so
indeed there are a number of genes
including those that are shown
uh the middle right here uh including
the one in red which obviously it's
large and red so it must be the most
important
uh that are that is known to influence
these these drugs
uh and so in this particular case
there's a variance of
of the liver enzyme cytochrome p450
2c19 or sit 2c19 as it's called
in the business there's a variant of
that called star 17
it was a 17 17 variant found and
that variant is known to increase
rather than decrease the amount of of uh
c9p protein that's produced cause the
enzyme to work better because it's
there's more of it and get rid of the
drug faster
and so trying to understand if a person
has
the the jazzed up version of this gene
the one that is as
gonna work especially well or a normal
version of it is important
and so uh ourselves and others dr kevin
hicks led this work
um got an algorithm together uh that
looked at a number of different features
but when it came down to it
you could genotype someone for the star
17 variant
of 2c19 ahead of given therapy
and they would either get the standard
200 milligram twice a day dose
that's shown kind of in the in the
middle lower middle part of this
of the screen or if they were rapid
metabolizer they would get
300 milligrams twice a day so a small
increase in the dose
but if they were an ultra rapid
metabolism they had two copies of the
star 17
there is super high enzyme activity
there is no dose of horoconsole you can
give that will be adequate
and so they need to go to a completely
different anti-fungal agent
and so this idea that you give one pill
one and a half pills or switch drugs
is really simplistic it's fancy genomics
and fancy data
but then at the end of the day is a
small change in dose
or a change to a different drug that
allows you to achieve precision medicine
and so that type of thing is just an
example of of how things are going and
when you look at whether it's been
successful um
if you look at those people who needed
the dose adjustment uh
about um 40 of them were within these
green bars the
the standard uh targeted range uh when
you
when you uh adjusted the dose for
genotype
those people that needed the 300
milligram preset dose
now after the adjustment 80 percent of
them were in the target range
one person was above the target range
but thankfully did not have
any side effects that's uh uh still a
good thing
and then there were four patients who
were below the green bar
for reasons we still haven't figured out
they seem to be taking the medicines
we don't know genetically if there's
something else going on but
a much smaller percentage of patients
were in trouble
in terms of that thing and when you look
at the overall numbers
it ends up being about 20 allele
frequency in the population so that
means that about
25 of the population uh will will have
this variant
in the u.s uh white and black population
it's a little bit different numbers in
asia and in
in other parts of the world but
certainly in western europe and in the
united states and australia
you're going to see a lot of patients
that can benefit from this sort of
intervention
because it's a very common event one in
four will need some sort of adjustment
uh for for the therapy so that's a
that's a big number
as you're going forward you can also
look at the cost and this is data for
the united states
uh where you looked at the budget impact
analysis and identified that
if you looked at the the cost of a
patient getting a fungal infection
it costs almost a little bit more than
thirty thousand dollars
in the first year extra to manage that
patient because of the drugs
because of the intensive nursing uh
often admitted
to the intensive care unit itself a lot
more expense
happens with these patients and so if
you prevented a small number of these
cases
you could more than pay for uh the
entire program
uh because of the benefits though there
and so these sorts of economic analysis
we'll come back to them
it's really important if you're a
scientist discovering variants in
in uh in in genomic uh in
pharmacogenomic areas
if you're a person who's involved in
biomarkers
you do need to understand about the
economics
because that's how your science can be
become routine
much more rapidly is by knowing how is
it going to help
uh the the dollar to be stretched the
euro to be stretched
whatever it is to be stretched in a way
that can benefit the population
now if you look at these different
examples i talked about
sip 2c19 the one example if you look at
the the clinical
pharmacogenomics implementation
consortium or cpic as it's shown
and also some data from the personalized
medicine coalition
but from the ctek data this is a group
of people from
about 40 different countries there's
about 300 individuals that all
contribute to guidelines
on whether you should uh or what you
should do
if you have a particular genetic variant
in terms of medicine
and so there are some examples uh like
the the top right example was cstr where
there's just one medicine
that's in the guideline there are other
examples like uh the left hand
two down uh sip2d6 has
a codeine and some other pain pain
medicines has tricyclope antidepressants
uh ssri antidepressants has tamoxifen
has some antioxidant vomiting has
medicine for adhd
lots of different types of medicines
that are included in the same guideline
and so you can see the the uh the type
of data that's emerging
and growing um on a uh a monthly basis
uh the the applications are starting to
get there
get there in terms of how does one use
this in the routine care of patients and
not just
as part of a clinical trial
it's also important to realize that
patients have multiple genomes
that matter i mentioned a previous
example of patients with a fungal
infection in that case
the especially if you're a patient with
leukemia and a fungal infection
you have your your leukemia genome
you have the fungus's genome which can
be involved with resistance
and then you also have the normal genome
that is is regulating
a lot of the toxicities that could occur
and so in cancer you certainly need to
know the tumor genome
and the germline genome the normal
tissue genome because of uh
of uh efficacy and toxicity respectively
and so this idea that we're looking at
multiple genomes is really important
and so focusing initially on the the
idea of of what do we do
on the tumor side it used to be that
things were rather simple
so if you saw a tumor in the colon was
shown in the the upper left-hand side
you tumor in the colon was called a
colon cancer
and if you looked at it under the
microscope and stained it with uh
uh hematoxylineasin um you saw some
glandular formation you call it an
adenocarcinoma of the colon or maybe uh
in the lower right hand side and you
sequenced it for k-rats
you now have a k-ras mutant abdo
carcinoma
of the colon simple linear type of fuss
well that is really blown up now into a
completely different paradigm
and what we're seeing now is you
sequence a tumor
identify what genes are are are altered
and then match those to medications and
so certainly her2 copy number
breast cancer was an early example of
this but now we're seeing her2 copy
number of lung cancer
and in gastric cancer and other cancers
being therapeutically relevant
there are some genes like the second one
shown there tp53
which does not have any drugs associated
with it yet
hopefully that'll change um and
therefore is found
is of biological relevance but not
necessarily a therapeutic problem
and then the list goes on in terms of
the medicines but this idea
that we look at what is driving the
tumor and then treat accordingly is now
emerging as a very viable approach
a very cost-effective approach to to um
choosing therapy for patients so it's
not just guessing
hoping to get it half right but seeing
what is driving it and try to use it
accordingly
and there's some nice data emerging
around this so this is a study that was
posed in general a couple years ago
what you see is an orange line that is
looking at
whether you if you gave if you sequest
the tumor the lung cancer
and you saw a driver and then you
targeted that driver with the therapy
you have the the survival curve that's
shown in orange on this plot
if you sequence the the patient's tumor
and you found a driver but you did not
act on it
that's shown in blue the light blue
excuse me and then
in uh sorry dark blue and then in light
blue or patients who did not have any
drivers
and therefore targeted therapy was not
guided based on
on the molecular event and what you can
see is whether you have no drivers
or whether you've ignored the drivers
your your
opportunities are worse than if you
found a driver and acted on it and it's
an important part because
just sequencing a tumor is not enough
sequencing a tumor applying precision
medicine and then making sure
that you get a medicine from that is the
key
and so this isn't precision genomics
it's precision medicine
you're trying to identify can you alter
care and so you have studies like that
here's another study
that was published a smaller study
looking at a number of different types
of solid tumors there's 12 different
types of solid tumors in this particular
study
and what you see here is the the
patients who got targeted therapy
lived almost twice as long as the
patients who
who did not get targeted therapy one
thing of note
is that the economic analysis of these
patients found that
those who got the targeted therapy had
less expense for their care even when
you included the cost of genomic testing
and so this idea that precision medicine
has to be more expensive
is not true because in many cases
you're choosing the better therapy it's
controlling the disease so keeping them
out of the
emergency department it's causing
fewer uh visits to the doctor
because there's not extra business for
toxicity or such it's allowing you to
manage the patient
in a way that benefits them uh and and
can be economically uh
viable as well so some really nice data
that's being generated
in that case now in terms of sequencing
the
the tissue i've i've uh showed you some
examples of that
previously and that one paradigm slide
but there's also the ability to do a
so-called liquid biopsy
so when you look at a circulating in the
circulating plasma
or serum what you see is
a bunch of different proteins but you
see a lot of nucleic acid
every time you sneeze some dna is
squirted into your bloodstream
uh and uh and and so
that that sort of dna can be uh
separated out
and can be quantitated and when you look
for mutations for alterations
it's you can then look and say well how
many how much of this dna
is from a tumor mutation compared to
what's been seen uh for the the uh the
normal tissue
which is the majority of the dna
circulating in your bloodstream
and so this is a case where they took
the tissue and
lung cancer where they took a piece of
tissue they measured it they found two
alterations
one that was actionable and where they
could use this particular drug or lotis
one that was not actionable a few months
later
uh four months later they did a liquid
boxy took a blood sample
sent it out and separated the dna uh
from the
the plasma and serum uh
and then we're able to make that and you
can see some new changes that were
occurring
including the alterations that are that
is shown in yellow
that caught that is known to cause
resistance to her lot now
and so you could switch to a different
epidermal growth factor receptor blocker
that is able to overcome this particular
genetic variant
well four months later you look and in
gold here
or orange you see yet another variant
has emerged
this one causes resistance to oh
suburban
so you now have resistance emerging to
um
to the the drug you switch to you know
that staying on it
is not a good idea and so in this case
there were other options
uh the their bq was not known to be
actual at that point in time
and so therefore uh the the patient went
on classical chemotherapy
three months later they were measured
again now you have
lots of different variants happening so
many that there are now enough
neoantigens
to justify the patient going in a
clinical trial for immunotherapy in this
case the doublet
immunotherapy and so that idea that
somebody
can can be changing therapies based on
molecular events
is quite important now in this
particular case
this patient has now been on this
clinical trial for over two years
you'll notice that the longest she she
uh obtained
a benefit previously was four months on
the different therapy
um now is has shot a therapy that has
given her benefit
for multiple years she still has
positive disease it's just being kept in
control
but the idea that you can use genomics
to respond to
emerging resistance and find new
therapeutic approaches
that will give that patient a better
option is a key piece of
what's emerging from from the precision
medicine era
part of the reason it's emerging is that
there are lots of different medicines
that are out there
not all of them will be available in
your country but at least in the united
states these are all approved medicines
and the point was not to make it so you
can see the name of them all
the point was for you to know there's a
lot of choices
if you go to a buffet and you don't
really want to eat oysters or you're
tired of eating beef
there's chicken there's fish there's
other things that you can eat at that
buffet
similar thing here look at what is
driving the cancer
and then choose a therapy that stops
that driver is now the paradigm that
we're seeing emerging
more and more data justifying the its
application
and so we'll you'll be seeing that
happening throughout the
the therapy for cancer
going forward this has caused some
unique
clinical issues to emerge some new
disciplines are being developed
so for example if you order an mri scan
or a ct scan
radiology has you back they can help you
order the proper scan they can help you
interpret the scan
and go forward you uh order a biopsy
the individual radiologist can biopsy it
the pathologist can read it
they have your back if you order
sequencing
tumor sequencing in particular who is
there to help you
the testing labs do a fantastic job of
making sure that the
there's high quality of results of what
is wrong
in a patient's tumor but what do you do
with it
how do you know what to do that is where
it's difficult and so
we're seeing uh we're seeing a number of
entities uh that have um
come out that are now trying to do a
a medical review of the pathology review
and so this is a particular company um
that's in the united states
that does a very fine job of sequencing
tumors
i have no relation there i'm not trying
to promote them just happen to be an
example
but their reports are 26 pages long if
you want to read through all of it
and try to really understand it it can
take you hours if you're not an expert
in this area
so there's some helpful information on
the front but also other information
that's not in this case and the the
the patient also got an expert
molecular tumor board review and
therefore this section in blue this
small little section
in the upper middle part of there uh is
all that the oncologist has to read
so in less than 30 seconds they can see
what the therapeutic options are
they're ranked by medical people and
therefore
they can quickly go in and apply this uh
to
to uh to their patient in a much more
rapid fashion
so this idea that there are our folks
that are now
uh helping translate the therapeutic
review from the pathology report
into the medical decision it's a really
important
aspect of submerging um going uh going
forward now i mentioned uh this slide
before
but i've now uh included the title take
off the blinkers
and included this picture i found of
arnold schwarzenegger
i have no idea why he was wearing these
i guess he was at a
horse track or something but the idea
that um
often we're looking at one gene in
isolation
you know maybe 62 c19 because we're
looking at
four contol for a leukemia patient but
in reality
these genes are often measured in a
panel situation
so all of these genetic variants are all
these genes
will be evaluated for genetic variants
at once
and so the idea that you need to respond
to uh
having all this different you might have
ordered a test
to look at one drug but that particular
test
might influence a number of drugs so
symptom 19
there's antidepressants there's
antiplatelet drugs there's antifungal
drugs
there's proton pump inhibitors for for
the gi tract
that will all have implications for that
that test you order but then you also
have all the other information so we're
now seeing a need
to really think about how do we look
more broadly
at the patient so this little girl uh
this
is a is a picture that i got off of
google images but as an example of a
real little girl
uh there's a girl that helps care for
that is a four-year-old with cystic
fibrosis
if you look forward she has
uh she is currently on or getting ready
to be on cystic fibrosis
antiseptic fibrosis medicines the
cystic fibrosis patients often have some
plural pain so they need
pain control if they need any surgical
procedures
or any any pulmonary procedures
they're on anta medics for the
anesthesia
they often might need a blood thinner or
they might need uh
some other other antibiotics some other
medicines
you know should they get depression they
need antidepressants
you can now think about this little girl
much more broadly
not only to choose which medicine she
gets right away for cystic fibrosis
but to be prepared for which pain
control to give her
which antidepressant should she need one
which of the antiplatelet drugs etc
she's going forward and so the idea that
you can look broadly across the patient
and not just at the one gene one drug
relationship
is a key piece of making this stuff
routine
the idea that that we are focused on one
dream one drug
was fine back in the day but now we need
to be thinking about
what is this patience outlook how do we
help them
going forward and that's an important
part of this now
the uh last little piece i'm going to
remind us about the billing aspect
this is a very american-centric but it
has relevance for the rest of the world
but if you don't understand how things
are built you cannot use that as a stick
to help the science happen faster if you
love your science and you think that it
is ready to change practice
you need to then talk about think about
the economics because it has to be
practical
and the economics have to work in order
for things to happen that doesn't matter
whether you're in europe
or whether you're in asia or whether
you're in south america or
in north america all of those countries
the economic drives the availability of
care and the
the uh the uh access to the medicines
itself
um and so it's important to look at what
we're seeing now not only can you bill
for the uh clinical encounter
but there are a number of other almost
non-medical aspects that are emerging so
for example there are many different uh
employers that are including
pharmacogenomics as part of the wellness
benefit
because they know that they can try to
retain the patient
the employee at their company because
they're a high-tech company they're
they're doing uh
wellness programs they're doing
pharmacogenomics therefore
they are a company on the cutting edge
you just stay there
it also shows the benefit from the cost
savings that occur
lots of different opportunities and so
the employers are starting to pay for
pharmacogenomics
by themselves not having the insurance
company involved at all
as they're as they're going forward um
and i'll skip over that's the interest
of time
you're also seeing some life insurance
products where you go out there
and as part of the life insurance
product you uh should you get cancer
you now get a nurse navigator a few
other things but you get your genomics
paid for already
so you don't have to convince your
doctor to to submit the test
um and then wonder what other whether
it'll be paid for it's already paid for
and so this idea that um
life insurance is better online than
health insurance
um because life insurance wants you to
live longer because that's how they make
their money
um is quite an interesting concept as we
go forward
you can line up with a drug margin so
there are places where they've done the
calculations since a
particular calculator done the
calculations that identify that
if they can get the medicine paid for
they will
get their percentage of that as they uh
as they
as it comes back to the administration
uh of the
the clinic and therefore they'll eat the
cost of the testing
to get to the real money which is in the
the drug reimbursement
and so that sort of thing is we're now
seeing you also see the total cost of
care so
uh looking more broadly you you can see
panels that are
looking across pharmacogenomics for for
cancer patients
also looking at germline for choosing
new therapies and then also looking at
risk of severe toxicities that can occur
and so looking broadly at this you can
start saying well what would the
economics be
i've already mentioned about some of the
pharmacogenomics but if you take a
severe toxicity like neuropathy
this is uh three different clinical
cohorts breast cancer ovarian cancer
lymphoma
occurs between six and thirteen percent
of the population
and what you see is that the patients
that have
in this case lymphoma and
neuropathy they end up costing
again almost 30 000 extra in the first
year
compared to the patients with lymphomas
the same lymphoma
and no neuropathy they also are
responsible for
15 extra clinic visits compared to
extra from the the ones that are
are the would normally be seen for
lymphoma patients
so this idea that by looking at severe
toxicities
you can save some costs from severe
toxicity and
changing to a more expensive drug etc
you can also
make your clinic a little bit more open
for new patients
that that's causing a lot of practices
now to say all right i'm just going to
do this
going going forward now in the interest
of time i'm going to jump over this but
what we're seeing is
how do we deliver this sort of thing
people often have multiple different
doctors
people now have multiple different drugs
they need to take into account
and we're seeing examples uh this is
just one example
i'm not trying to promote it over any
others but examples where you can have
your
genes your drugs your medic your medical
history your allergies your lifestyle
be able to put in the medicines
regardless of which doctor would
prescribe them and be able to manage
them in a more holistic fashion
and so we're seeing tools like this
emerge and starting to be applied
going forward so i'll uh i'll
end up going in and closing uh with the
this this slide um that just as a
reminder
that lots of different examples are are
there in terms of
precision medicine and even more are
coming your favorite disease
your favorite drug is next in terms of
trying to apply that
and so we have again examples where
we can now use select therapy among
equals
the idea that there's a best therapy and
second best therapy is really outdated
most of the time we know there's a bunch
of
really good therapies we don't know that
one is better than another for an
individual person
unless we look and try to identify risk
of toxicity risk of other things
areas like pediatrics they never have
level one a type one evidence
evidence-based medicine they always have
to go with small studies or
make inference from adult studies and so
many areas of medicine do this and so
the idea that we can use this and apply
it
is critical rational therapeutics risk
mitigation
the budget impact all can be influenced
uh
by by precision medicine and are
areas where the accountants and the
administrators who are often the
obstacles to
to uh new innovations um can be
influenced because they now
are going to realize hey we can do
better we can be a better hospital we
could save costs we can
keep our doctors keep our nurses keep
our pharmacists um
that sort of thing is influenced by this
now that we're looking across the
patients we do something for them today
maybe in a hospital
how are we going to make sure that they
benefit from this information
when they go to their endocrinologist or
their primary care physician or whoever
it is
they might see in the future again
different ways of discharging patients
thinking about their needs
different ways of doing discovery in
terms of what's the best way
and then lastly we need to make sure
that we're asking the patient about the
toxicity
if if i think that toxicity is severe
it doesn't matter it's what the patient
thinks
i might think it's fine the patient
thinks it's terrible or
the patient that we're trying to help
not the clinician not the researcher not
that
so we need to be asking them and with
with patients uh
patient-derived outcome of data uh this
can feed back
and allow us to really direct the care
of going forward
uh to to really achieve things in a much
better way so
this is the last slide i'm gonna stop at
this point i hope you've uh
picked up a few little tips and nuances
as we went along
there's a great uh rest of the session
um that's coming up right after this
and and it's really exciting time to
look at this week
and really the the broad spectrum of
topics that lab roots is putting
together
and trying to make it so that we can
enhance our knowledge
and make our research better make our
clinical care better
make things better for those that we
care about so i want to thank you very
much for your time thank you